well let's keep going so we've got
functions we've got circles really
knowing the equation of a circle how to
find the center in the radius the
multiplication counting principle this
is a way of finding out how many events
there are or how many possible outcomes
averages so again you know we know what
an average is like when you find the
average in your math class but sometimes
we'll have you solving for different
quantities maybe like a test score you
know that you need to get to boost your
average up to 90 percent or things like
that so it might not just be like a
straightforward average problem knowing
the distance formula the midpoint
formula the slope formula these are all
key formulas you want to know equations
of lines okay your slope intercept or
your y equals MX plus B form of the line
also standard form of a line and how to
graph lines factoring so really knowing
some of the basic rules for factoring
graphing lines and inequalities okay
logarithms and they don't get too deep
into logs but just knowing how to
evaluate a log is key
let's see parallel lines and angles okay
so you probably remember from geometry
when you had two parallel lines cut by a
transversal knowing all those different
angles corresponding angles alternate
interior angles and so on percentages
really knowing how to work with
percentages there's usually one or two
problems on there about that probability
pretty straightforward just finding out
the chance something that's going to
occur proportions and again the other
thing to realize is that they don't
always come right out and tell you hey
this is a proportion problem but if you
can recognize that it's a proportion
problem it's going to be a lot easier to
set it up and solve
of course the Pythagorean theorem so
this is with right triangles the a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
Pythagorean triples that kind of thing
rules of exponents okay knowing your
multiplication rules division rules
product rules slope okay the angle of
the line right solving inequalities okay
knowing some of the rules like if you
multiply or divide by a negative number
special right triangles these are the 30
60 90 and 45-45-90 triangles and knowing
all the different relationships between
the sides right triangle trigonometry so
this is sometimes thought of as the soap
Toula so knowing the different ratios
the sine ratio cosine ratio tangent
ratio on how to solve for solve for the
missing sides and then perimeter area
and volume just real basic you know
knowing knowing what those are and how
to work with those so these are 21
concepts that are definitely tested on
the acct definitely something you want
to be familiar with and comfortable with
I go into these in depth in the course
that I put together I give a little
lesson on each different topic and then
I actually give you some practice
problems that you can do on your own and
I have an answer key so we go through
these you know one by one so you can get
a little bit more experience with that
but in this video I wanted to also show
you one of these okay 21 concepts just
to get you started and again like I said
you can go ahead and reference my AC T
playlist on my channel to get more into
depth into some of these other concepts
but I'll get you started in this video
with just working with functions and
this is an easy way to boost your score
by one or two possibly two points if
you've gotten these problems wrong in
the past they're very easy to get
they're just in a slightly different
format than what you're seeing used to
seeing in your class so let me show you
how that works okay so let's get into
how to work with functions and on the AC
T it's a little bit different than what
you're used to seeing in your class so
let me show you what you see normally in
your class normally you see something
like this right f of X equals 2x plus 3
and then your math teacher will say what
is F of negative 1 and you just
recognize okay whatever is in the
parentheses that's my input I'm putting
that in for X on the right side of the
equation and I'm simplifying so if we
were to do that for this problem it
would be 2 times negative 1 plus 3 so
that's negative 2 plus 3 which equals 1
so this is the input and 1 is the output
so that's our straightforward function
that we're used to seeing in our math
class and it's not to say that you won't
see something similar on the AC T like
this you will as well but what they
sometimes do is they change it up a
little bit just to make sure that you
understand the general idea of how these
functions work and I'll give you another
example so see it'll give you something
like this will say if a square be equals
a minus 3b then what does for square one
equal okay now before you panic and and
just skip that question okay
just realize that this is also a
function we've never seen a square
before so it's not like this is
something you haven't learned they're
just telling you that okay look for is
what a equals and one is what B equals
so if you just do the substitution
you've got it so it's going to be two
times four minus three times one so
that's eight minus three which equals
five so that was pretty easy so it
should only take you you know maybe 15
20 seconds and you're onto the next
question
adding extra points to your final score
let me show you another example okay
these concepts they're also covered on
the SAT and the PSAT so say for example
you had one like this say it was a b c
equals a plus B minus C so you say I
never saw a triangle like that in my
math class what do I do
so say they give you something like this
it's three to one and you say okay what
is this you say you know yeah before you
get confused just recognize it's a
function they're just saying that we're
putting three in for a tune for B and
wanted for C okay and so again we'll
just do that real quick so it's three
plus two minus one so that's four okay
and they use all different kinds of
symbols like they might just say like a
star B you know and any kind of symbol
like that and it might be even more
complicated they might say a star B box
C okay but if you just recognize you
know the pattern that's what you're
going for is you're saying can you
recognize the pattern can you substitute
that quantity and on the right side and
simplify if you can then you really
understand functions and you know of
course you get rewarded for a point for
that so I hope you enjoyed this video
like I said go ahead and review these
concepts see if they're if you're
lacking and understanding any of those
check out the playlist and if you're
interested in digging further go ahead
and check out the the course in the
description I'll have a link for that
for below if you want to check that out
more and I look forward to helping you
further with your math I'll talk to you
soon